what are you doing
just waiting Stark Julie oh it started
that's my water bottle Julia thank do
you god it's me Jim please give me the
patience to put up with my every
boyfriend today and dear God also give
me more energy anymore dig dig dig
welcome back to the Jillian podcast this
episode is brought to you by the skin
the daily newsletter that gives you in
the know it is completely free all you
got to do is subscribe by going to th es
ki mmm the scam dot-com / Jena Julien
you get entered to subscribe to the
newsletter comes in your email inbox
every morning it's a nice concise chunk
of information about what's going on in
the world and it's completely free so
check it out also you're entered to win
into a $50 Visa gift card when you sign
up using that URL also guys thread up I
don't know what you but when I go to
thrift stores or when I go to secondhand
clothing stores I get overwhelmed it's
kind of nuts in there oftentimes you're
not exactly sure where to find what you
want thread up is the solution for that
they're the world's biggest online
consignment and thrift store with up to
90 percent off retail price they got
great brands but in a republic BCBG Kate
Spade Lululemon all the good stuff
alright now go to THR edu pthread up
comm slash annejulien
and you get an extra 30% off today and
you don't have to leave your bed correct
time alright ladies and men or you don't
have to leave your cot if you sleep on a
cot or your couch if you sleep on a
couch sometimes people sleep in chairs
you don't have to leave your chair I've
known certain people sleep standing up
you don't have to leave your spot now
I've known certain people that sleep
sitting up certain people you know is
upside down
I showed Julian a video of a bat eating
a banana earlier I was a dog who's a dog
the bad it was not a bad it's a bad how
can we how could it be about if it was a
dog the big bats are so cute though
they're so cute but they're they're
they're feral that's a feral you know
where they are they these they're feral
visions phone are speaking of being real
smart and knowing phone are not even a
minute into the pod guys and I said the
word feral vision speaking of yes
someone suggested in one of our older
podcasts it we're gonna be embarrassed
like this is an embarrassing podcast but
they suggested that we play a style of
game like are you smarter than a 5th
grader which I used to play on my iPad
all the time when it was like
competitive and online it was really fun
you know but that game doesn't really
exist anymore I don't think that's a TV
show - right that's where I came I don't
know if it's still in the air but it it
was at one point with Jeff Foxworthy is
the host and each like adult was paired
with an actual 5th grader and they would
play together or some stuff like that so
I don't even know if this is like we
have the legit questions from the show
or whatever but we looked it up and I
found a website that gave like a hundred
and seventy something questions 176 I
think questions we have to determine oh
yeah these are fifth-grade trivia
questions but like I mean the one thing
that that show proves is like in fifth
grade you learn a lot of stuff that you
just don't it's like when you learn
cursive it's like a lot of the stuff
doesn't really help you be a person you
just learn it well Alex Trebek always
said like the best people on Jeopardy
were like teachers because they're just
you know exposed to all this information
all the time whereas when you're an
adult you just even a smart adult yeah
you just like don't use a lot of that
information and if you did learn it at
one point so what we'll do is we can go
through me
right now don't make fun of me yeah I'm
gonna be embarrassed - are you kidding
me I'm doing worse than you man we're
gonna go through these questions but
we're also gonna go at a pace where
we're not like spitting out answers
super fast so you can play a long way
together right we can work together but
if we have different answers we can move
forward with different answers so that
like if you if you say different answer
than me you'd be wrong and then I'd be
right like do I want to quiz each other
let's work together
she didn't shake my hand are you smarter
than a 6th oh I'm just kidding it's
fifth are you smarter than a 5th grader
because there's going to be a test later
tell your teachers now you're back in
school oh this is a theme song you're
reading a theme song yeah tell your
teachers now you're back in school are
you smarter than you used to be are you
smarter than a 5th grader grab a pencil
and a piece of paper or tell your
teachers now you're back in school are
you smarter than you used to be B oh
that's what it says question number 1
3rd grade geography blog what is the
capital of Massachusetts
I know Salem I'm going with Salem it's
Boston that's where the witch trials
work yes the capital the capital they
held the witch trials only in the
capital oh ok this is wrong I got it ok
we're not linking this website it's
wrong no it's fun at Halloween I've
never I've never been sailing by the way
I know it's in Massachusetts but where
is it I don't actually remember but like
you drive out of Boston and then you get
to Salem that sounds like a child's
directions yeah you know like you sit in
the backseat and that's how you remember
an actual thing ok question number two
2nd grade health true or false the small
intestine is longer than the large
intestine true I think it's I think it's
true also true before you do you have to
like explain your reasoning it's true
mr. just zoomed through the quiz with
sale
and click on the incident it's true it's
true we don't have to worry about it
anymore because it's true ok but you're
not giving anyone a chance to play at
home yeah I said I would didn't I yeah
you did
because you're holding the phone you
come up with an answer and you just
click on it you're not thinking about
anybody else why am i why am i holding
the phone and you're not because my
phone's about to die
oh what a new story that is your phone
dead are you more spiteful than this
yeah alright question number 3 3rd grade
astronomy ok what is another name for
the North Star alpha alpha centauri
Polaris or serious
I think it's belarus belarus or serious
what do you think Julian before you
click on over here I think it's Alpha
Centauri explain your reasoning Wow
alpha I don't know it just sounds like
there's two words in Alpha Centauri and
then the North Star is two or three
words so I think it's Polaris okay I
think it's office enjoy okay answer
three it's polarity I'm not doing too
hot so far
it was players okay they're color coded
I don't know if that means they're
easier hard yeah I think I think yellow
is easy green is medium and red is that
doesn't make extra medium why are they
cars on the green would be easy yellow
is medium and red is hard
why are they are they that's a question
okay that's a question before why are
these arranged can I skip around or
second grade measurements mmm how many
meters in a kilometer I know the answer
I do not what do you have choices no I
think it's a thousand a thousand meters
yeah because if you think about it cuz
if you think oh it's a kilo lammeter
qu'il um
thousand llamas good llama math not the
reason I would think is because a
hundred meters is about a football field
well what would a hundred meters be
called I don't think there's a little
mean a hundred or a thousand kilos a
thousand kilo oh because of one gram a
1000 grams is one kilogram or a hundred
no how much is a gram wait a kilometer
is it a kilogram is 2.2 pounds so that's
definitely a thousand grams it's not a
Holmes so you think one kilometer is one
thousandth of a thousand no I think it's
one thousand two one thousand of a
kilometer my answer to your question is
I think one kilometer is one whole
kilometer because okay because when you
go kilometers in a car you don't see the
speed limit like seven hundred
kilometers yeah I think it's out of a
hundred
what so we know out of where did you get
oh yeah Mohammed no kilometer is like
what was the question
20 meters how many meters in a kilometer
I think I think a hundred okay how many
meters so that means a football field is
a kilometer that could be right though
that could be right so say you're going
20 kilometres an hour I don't know I
don't go you're going slow as a
[ __ ] because it means in an hour
you only drove past 20 football fields
one hour God answer was a thousand so a
thousand thousand impeccable logic also
our deduction was great like we showed
our work on the paper yes and I hope all
of you that use kilometers in other
countries you got a good laugh at us for
that because it took a while to get
there but we got it right first grade
grammar let's do what is the root word
of the word longest long the root word
yeah what's your
sir the route is long the extension or
whatever you call it is missed it's so
it's long I go with long the route oh
it's long yeah got it
now that a bell we don't have about I
have a sound board my phone's gonna die
hold on stop playing water it's a gong
sick oh I actually pressed a question
third grade social studies how many
justices serve on the US Supreme Court
oh [ __ ] I'm so bad at this stuff
everything that we learned in social
studies in history just like never went
into my brain he's nine it might be 11
or 12 915 1125 who the [ __ ] knows this
is so embarrassing nightmares but I
don't know 9 final answer I'm gonna go
with your answer because I'm not
confident 9 oh good job I knew that I
did it it said answer number 19 so I
thought there was 19 could you get that
confusion you understand where I came
came across that confusion it was 9 5th
grade earth science what element
comprises the majority of Earth's
atmosphere nitrogen nitrogen what makes
you think that I think it's oxygen the
atmosphere and not the hydrogen oh the
atmosphere yeah carbon hydrogen nitrogen
oxygen
well cuz up in the atmosphere right what
it what is it what is it
yeah we're [ __ ] right now well
nitrogen is not a bad guess definitely
not carbon it's either oxygen or
nitrogen or carbon monoxide
yeah carbon monoxide Richard that's not
an element that's a compound or
something I don't know I'm not I don't
know I say thank you
I say oxygen okay if it's hydrogen I
swear to God there was nitrogen yeah
nice job bebop who fob up beeps I'm
winning 10:00 to 3:00
third grade English what is the simple
past tense of the verb drink drank beach
I think it's drunk drank thing is drunk
oh is it drunk I don't think I don't
think drink is right I think Jake huh
it's drank this drank I was trying to
get too crafty with it his drink are you
overthinking more than a fifth grader
fourth grade world geography Bern is the
capital of what European country how do
you spell it BER and burn yeah I have no
clue European okay so we know it's not
Spain it's not France it's not Portugal
Germany it's not Germany Belgium like
Poland Bern Poland it's Bern I've know
not it's not Norway wow this is a
[ __ ] mess what a bloodbath
no I don't know that I've never heard
that name ever
I skipped fifth grade by the way did you
do double fourth grader you just go
right to sixth grade I started school in
sixth grade I was raised by wolves until
then burn I don't know and it's in
Europe I even know I don't know
burn BER n burn is there a time limit
yeah can we phone a friend
hey Siri no you can't what country is
burn the capital of Julian
ah that was easy we got our Sealand oh
you didn't even that was fourth grade
world geography I don't even think we
got out of the United States by fourth
grade 4th graders dude no we had like J
can't even walk it and they know that I
feel like in fourth grade we had just
learned like finished South America and
like Canada I can't remember what the
[ __ ] we learned in fourth grade I just
remember third grade I'm just a job fair
where we had to create our own
businesses uh-huh
it was pretty legit Wow I made a comic
strip business Wow
and I sold comic strips that's great and
I got shut down
why for selling other people's work oh I
did tell my own though all right moving
on first grade art the three secondary
colors are green purple and what other
color okay secondary colors I arranged
is it yeah well his primary arm yeah so
if you mix blue and yellow you get grain
red and blue um blue pencil and you mix
red and yellow and you get Aaron's
arrant orange
the answer is orange marker so far we're
just [ __ ] up these fifth grade really
good and men for comes fourth grade
non-binary friends first grade music oh
god what what are the following
instruments is part of the percussion
family who hit me
that was the Oh men go on viola knows I
love phone oh yes but soon it's a phone
I told you that story right like in
fourth grade when they you all go into
music right and they're like
demonstrating all the instruments and
they're like here's a flu and here's a
violin and here's the clarinet and
here's the trombone like all right
you're gonna go to like your section of
the
music room and you try out for three
instruments and like the guy was just up
there like playing the drums that was
the only thing that I wanted to try like
try out for and like try and play the
drums and I forgot where they said to go
to try out for the drums and I never
tried one I only tried the flute the
clarinet and the violin and at the end
of the day we had to pick one and I just
never said anything to anybody but I
really just wanted to play the drum so
bad and then I played the clarinet for
eight years
damn when you don't follow instructions
and you miss out on dream I get so
excited about him playing the drums that
I never heard where he said to go so I
didn't get to try out you could have
just asked think about what my life
would be like if I was like the most
badass girl drumming you ever seen it
would be Tyler Joseph and jenna mourey
not Joshua done exactly you would have
the yellow hair not me why didn't you
just like hey excuse me where do I go
for the trumps why don't you ever ask
for help you are the type of person to
politely shiver and freeze because
someone didn't tell you where the heats
which was and you freeze to death
because you're too polite to ask where
the heat is I'm too nervous
like we'll be in a store like a really
like a looking for something very
obscure and I'll just be like okay I'll
just go ask for help and it's like no no
no why would you ask so I'm like what
the hell
why would I don't ask for help bother
them that's where they're there of us
asking for help that's what they're do
but you're being a nuisance to me by
doing that because my day is now
extended where it doesn't need to be
because you're trying to be polite to
strangers okay but most times we don't
okay let's move on here
this isn't counseling one-on-one third
grade geography to are false the equator
passes through the southern tip of North
America false false false false
that would mean texas or Florida yeah
yeah well it's in South America yeah
watch us get [ __ ] bamboozled by this I
lost the question where is it oh my god
has to be false yeah passes through
Ecuador Brazil South America second
grade vocab what words starting with the
letter Q can mean both a spike on a
porcupine and a bird feather used as a
pen quill quill sorry I told you we were
gonna give you guys time to answer and I
didn't do it on though and I just want
to beat you Wow look at this I just
wanted to beat you I wanted to show off
that I knew what koalas that's big dick
is that the first time you said that out
loud yeah how'd it feel um weird that
you know okay
okay someone on stream last night said
I'd have big bird energy I kind of like
that it's kind of good second grade u.s.
geography and what u.s. state is the
lincoln home national historic site
located lincoln home national historic
site so that must be where his home was
right where he lived you know I haven't
got a clue so I'm just gonna say
Pennsylvania I feel like there's a lot
of museums in Pennsylvania I've been to
Gettysburg Pennsylvania is a really good
guess I would say either Pennsylvania or
Maryland cuz of DC but I don't know I
don't know that's all I have no idea
I've never I didn't know it was a thing
and I've never been there so I have no
idea
I'm gonna go West Virginia okay no I've
been there it's nothing you don't know
that West Virginia's we don't know
anything okay so you're Pennsylvania and
West Virginia Illinois and that was a
bamboozle really Illinois all right we
done [ __ ] up first grade grammar what
word is the subject of the following
sentence the spaceship landed in Jacobs
backyard what word is the subject Jacob
spaceship
the subject is what the sentence is
about right because I mean Jacob is the
person in the sentence is a descriptor
for the environment spacious about the
spaceship if it was gonna say Jacob's
backyard was home to the spaceship it
would be about Jacobs nature well I mean
I think so I think you're right I think
it's definite could just mean the person
but I don't [ __ ] know spaceship first
grade measurements true or false in a
leap year there are more days in January
/ February combined than in November /
December combined oh my god okay so
there's 31 days in January how many days
in February on a leap year 28 29 2008
when t9 cuz it's leap year right so
what's 29 + 31 2007 is 60 and then
what's the second half of the question
is it more on a leap year than
November's last December combined how
many days were there in November because
you know there's 31 July August
September October November there's 30
days in November and 631 days so there's
61 in November / December so there's
still more in November December even on
a leap year yeah in a leap year there
are more days in January that's us false
wait we [ __ ] up no it's false I'm
guessing Paulson is false yeah wait so
explain that so in a leap year the
question the question is true or false
in a leap year there are more days in
January + February than there are in
November + December and the answer was
false because we concluded there's one
more day in November and + December even
in a year even in a leap year two more
days in a regular fourth grade science
which subatomic particle is not
contained within the nucleus of an atom
proton Neutron electron electron it's
outside wait what's your answer don't
just click on the answer I'm not
clicking on anything I'm just thinking
it's in here the electrons outside going
hey Beach is me
I'm electric yeah curette was the hustle
[ __ ] up correct yes correct
fourth grade mathematics if a car is
traveling 40 miles per hour how long
does it take to drive a hundred and
ninety miles I'm dumb I don't know I
used to do these math problems all the
time
forty miles always stomach so you would
drive 40 miles in one hour so then
another forty miles in another hour so
take you hours to drive a hundred and
sixty miles to then three three fourths
so it's basically 0.75 times 60 0.75
times what 75% of 60 see I'm all we're
complicating this I know I am yeah but
you're doing the problem different than
I would okay to two shades what's the
total again 190 miles 30 yeah so 30
remaining after you go 160 which is
already four hours so it's four hours
plus change and the change is 75% of an
hour 75 times six there's an extra 25
minutes in there right
no because 25 is less than half of an
hour yeah it would be 40 45 is 3/4 oh
it's 45 it's 4 hours and 45 minutes yeah
4 hours 45 minutes yep that's my guess
we did it took a while to get there but
we got there I used to love those ones
like the situational I love those now
second grade health true or false the
human shoulder is a ball-and-socket
joint that's that's got to be true Balan
Saket I'm pretty sure that's true that's
why you can pop it out I only know this
because of the extensive shoulder
problems is not like a hinge and it's
not like um I don't know what you call
like the rest of your body but like it's
a ball socket it can rotate around in a
circle like this and not just back and
forth
I've had enough physical therapists
explain to me what's wrong with my
shoulder to know that it's evolved
yes that's true the work okay let's go
have these been stumping to you so far
only the ones that are like geography
and/or the math ones about like going
far but like I can get they're just
gonna take me a minute you know okay
second grade math in history or
geography I'm not very good at I've
never been my entire life second grade
math okay a product is discounted by 90%
Oh
plus the list price gets an additional
30%
what are you have the threat of discount
for Jenna Julianne you caught on early
you can't really I will give you that
you got a threat up.com slash and Julie
right now you get 90 percent off
name-brand items secondhand and great
quality and conditions but you get an
extra 30% off when you use thredUP comm
slash Jenna Julianne we're giving you
more discounts than you would normally
get guys right up I've been on a roll
lately I'm not gonna lie thread up is a
great way to get secondhand clothes
clothing without any of the hassle of
going to a thrift store or looking for
things because there's there's a lack of
organization in most thrift stores and I
get that but right now threat up has
over 35,000 brands such as the ones I
listed Lululemon Banana Republic like
high quality brands in good quality and
condition that you can get that the
discounts start at ninety percent off
retail price so you go browse around you
see what you like it could just be like
a situation where you're like hey I'm
just gonna go on the threat up see what
they have and then you find something
you're like oh [ __ ] that's pretty cheap
and then you close out the browser and
you go back into a new browser you go th
re DUP comm slash Jenna Julian and you
have an extra 30 percent off of that
cute pair of shoes that you were gonna
get oh and so now you have new clothing
and your wallet is still thick so check
it out they're going to thread up that's
thre DUP comm slash Jenna Julian you get
30% off plus an additional well sorry
90% off question is
30% when you use our URL or click the
link in our video description check it
out also guys this skim it is an awesome
newsletter that is delivered to your
email inbox every morning doesn't knock
at your door
doesn't take up physical paper you don't
have to buy it at the store you don't
have to load it on Twitter it just
arrives it's just like slides into your
inbox it's like hey what's up on the
skin and it gives you the bullet points
of all the major top news stories
happening in the world for that day
there's no opinions there's no nonsense
it's just what you need to know to go
out into the world and be the smartest
person in the room and let people know
about it well is that not part of it you
don't have to let people know you're the
smartest but if it comes down to it it
comes down to a battle of wits you will
win because of the skin it is a really
really convenient way to get your news
they they're you know what they are if
they're as consistent as my segways okay
so if you like consistency in your life
you like structure in your life the skin
is for you check it out go to th es ki
mm that's two M's hamsa and Julian
you're entered it's free you don't have
to pay anything and not only that but
you're entered to win a $250 Visa gift
card so check it out all right give it a
shot see what you like and maybe you'll
dominate some conversations at work
thank you thank you sponsors for giving
me the opportunity to do that every week
of my life all right
first grade social studies I already
don't like this Irving Berlin bro what
patriotic anthem that contains the word
stand beside her and guide her yes but
if they hadn't given us any of the
lyrics I would have struggled big-time
Oh
what you don't know Irving Berlin by
heart oh he don't yeah me too
it's got a Bless America is that isn't
the name of the song yet god bless
america the only one that I know is like
Francis Scott Key right
the national yeah no that's the
star-spangled banner' sorry
Ghazi but I know his name but that's it
I'm not good at that stuff second grade
world geography [ __ ]
France borders what ocean the Atlantic
if they had said like sea or bodies of
water yeah I was gonna say if they had
said they were at sea or just water well
it's the Atlantic Ocean in parentheses
and the Mediterranean Sea yeah that's
what I'm saying
so yeah we're good fourth grade
mathematics
yikes how many numbers between
fourth grade mathematics how many
numbers read the question out loud boy I
know I'm trying to like lost these
numbers these are so small how many
numbers between 10 and 20 are perfect
squares
well there's 16 that's a perfect square
that's it that's it now 20 so 16 and 20
but that's not between 21 perfect square
you're right 25 is it's 1 yeah the
answer is no the answer is 1 good job
nice first grade science which of the
following foods has seeds on the inside
orange potato carrot come on it's potato
the worst part orange when they get in
your mouth yeah no that's not fun
2nd grade animal science true or false
chickens are cold-blooded animals oh
wait hmm they are cold-blooded birds are
wait no they're not
birds are warm-blooded but they're not
mammals and they have feathers I think
we have to explain our reasoning my
reason is my reason is chickens no first
you need to go back and explain why 16
is a perfect square because perfect
square means that a number times itself
comes out to it a number
and that number is a perfect square so
four times wait four times four is 16
which means four is the square root of
16 that's what square root means so
anyways okay it's cold-blooded my
chickens are not cold-blooded because
they're not reptiles well the only
things that are cold-blooded are
reptiles amphibians and lizard people
what about fish I [ __ ] don't know but
I know that like whales aren't because
they're mammals I don't know that's a
separate question I don't know that
let's talk about whales let's talk about
whales can I get the answer to this I
think the chickens are warm-blooded
plus all birds are warm-blooded yeah
good job we did it and they're cute and
they're my favorite thing to watch on
the Internet and they cute i watch only
Barb memes fourth grade world geography
what country borders Spain to the west
Portugal is that your answer yeah I
guess huh it's not to the south yeah
well it's south and west but like what's
west of Spain aside from the water
I don't know answer the United States
Canada it's not Canada Portugal
all right Portugal I'm gonna go with
your answer I don't know the answer to
that damn what Portugal we've been there
I know but that doesn't mean I know the
geography okay maybe I should first
grade spelling the names of how many
days of the week do not start with T or
s Monday Wednesday Friday that's it
three yeah I'm not even gonna click on
that
three Monday Wednesday Friday
third-grade life sciences russet and
Yukon Gold are varieties of what
vegetable I only know this because I'm
vegan and I eat these all the time then
cuz it's pretty basic and they yummy
potato 2nd grade measurements if Jacob
stands on Spencer's shoulders how
annoyed is Spencer I'm just kidding they
are two and a half yards it's as yeards
but yards too high how many feet is that
isn't a yardstick like three feet
yardstick is three feet so two and a
half yards at 6 9 9 feet hmm three yards
yeah 9v wait yeah
no half so one and a half so six plus
one and a half is seven and a half
whoa two and a half so three six three
it's not seven and a half year right
seven laughs it's two and a half yards
it's basically saying how how many feet
is two in our yards three plus seven is
one and a half you're right good job
thanks ladies second grade astronomy
true or false the planet Jupiter has a
larger mass than Earth that's false
what it has a gigantic mass Jupiter
Jupiter isn't normal it's gaseous maybe
doesn't that have something to do with
it
I don't know how gaseous it's like maybe
Saturn's more gaseous than jus never
mind Jupiter's mass well yeah I mean
Jupiter's [ __ ] huge like you yeah
juicer is massive massive it has a lot
of mass I just solved the problem it's
false wait what was the question
I'll read it again planet Jupiter has a
larger mass than Earth true yes it has a
larger mass than Earth 18 times the size
of Earth yeah but it's gaseous okay just
want to point it out all right all right
we're gonna scoot on to some hard ones
okay now they're all the same
it's 5th grade 5th grade algebra if y
equals 3x and 3x I use a paper I can do
it invisible if y equals 3x and 3x
equals 12 what is y equal okay I need a
piece of paper 3x equals 12
okay
so you divide by 3 divided by 3 12 over
3x equals 4 so then 3 times 4y equals 12
okay so yeah I needed a piece of paper
for that but you write got it good work
I have to write it down
Hausa broght was one of my stronger
subjects that's hot third grade
measurements what unit of power is
abbreviated by the letter W watts
wattage watts it's also a city in Los
Angeles
what it is city of watts okay [ __ ] sorry
no it's in that famous very famous song
what's California knows how to party
California does he say why wasn't that
song in the city City of Compton in the
city city of watts I think he says that
what I think he says what's in that song
where are you are you saying I'm wrong I
don't know I really don't know I don't
know I I don't know Chile I got to find
it I got to find it hold on hold on we
just got to confirm this question first
yeah these are so small okay it's like a
light bulb 60 W is sixty Watts Watts
hopefully I'm not completely wrong and
that's in that song there bit fourth
grade earth science lightning is what
type of electricity current alternating
or static oh I would say alternating or
current no yeah it's current its wait is
it static energy because isn't that sort
of like what creates the lightning it
comes from like the static electricity
in the atmosphere so it would be
considered static energy I don't know if
that that means like static like when
you rub your hands together and put it
on your hair like that kind of static
injury or it means the type of energy
that is static I think you're I think
the first type of static is the right
way I don't know that's my yes
that's a good question though because I
don't know the answer what are you doing
I'm looking for the question I already
lost it well because the current would
be like it's static you're right
lighting is a giant version of static
shock yeah good job because that's like
it's not the same as the real word
static mm-hmm science word static wait
first grade spelling spelling I mixed
that word with the word podium has how
many vowels
oh I you three good three second grade
geography how many US states have the
word north south east west okay we can
do this you ready this is the only thing
I could do
Alabama Alaska Arizona Arkansas
California Colorado Connecticut Delaware
Florida Georgia Hawaii Idaho Illinois
Indiana Iowa Kansas Kentucky Louisiana
Maine Maryland Massachusetts Michigan
Minnesota Mississippi Missouri Montana
Nebraska Nevada New Hampshire yeah you
have to count new is not new is not one
it's not New Jersey New Mexico New York
North Carolina North Dakota Ohio
Oklahoma Oregon Pennsylvania Rhode
Island South Carolina South to go you
forgot
North and South Dakota got it good we
not lost sounds a double x now I'm
[ __ ] up Julian we could just do this
the normal way Oklahoma Oregon
Pennsylvania South Carolina South Dakota
I'm saying them Tennessee Texas but you
didn't count them way to Oklahoma Oregon
Pennsylvania Rhode Island South Carolina
South Dakota Tennessee Texas Utah
Vermont Virginia Washington West
Virginia Wisconsin well you owe me seven
wait seven let's I heard
I don't know okay no he's God no they
all started like we're after oh right
okay
Oregon Oregon Island South Carolina
South Dakota Tennessee Texas wait forgot
for South Carolina North Carolina
I already got Dakota's it's to cook
Dakotas Virginia Carolina we had the
answer if you would just count think
it's five West Virginia North Dakota
South Dakota North Carolina South
Carolina that's it
wait what's the first one West Virginia
okay I think it's five I mean I might be
completely wrong but I think it's five
South yeah no that's right what's the
answer the answer is five I got it right
no I got no you confused them no why I
named all the states that was not a song
by the way yes it is I've never learned
that song what's it called pleats
it's called fifty nifty United States
[Music]
China bottom tell about him one by one
to give it a day to every state in the
USA what months what month comes last
alphabetically I think it's January
February March April May June Jason
January February March April May June
July August September October November
September December it's gotta be
September September wake me up when
September when you hear September and I
hear September we hear two different
things first grade mathematics which of
the following is the smallest one third
one fourth
or marbles okay or 1/2 1/4 boy yeah easy
third grade social studies which is not
a member of the US presidential cabinet
a [ __ ] Secretary of Education be
Attorney General see White House press
secretary cabinet I think the Attorney
General is absolutely not in the cabinet
but I don't [ __ ] know I don't know
the answer to that I would agree I would
agree the Attorney General is its own
thing and we are wrong it's White House
press secretary we're a mess goddamn
that [ __ ] is hard sorry y'all please
don't make fun of us second grade
mathematics Stephen has a hundred
dollars in pennies how many pennies does
he have a dollars worth enough to get
some bubblegum wait here's a hundred
pennies asking how many pennies it's got
to be ten thousand what's the question I
wasn't listening hundred dollars in
pennies oh how many pennies yeah each
dollar is a thousand penny that's ten
thousand yeah or whatever wait how many
dollars
wait each dollar is a thousand pennies
each ten dollars is a thousand pennies
which is why ten times ten is ten
thousand I'm gonna confirm it I'm gonna
confirm it all right let's just cut out
okay ten thousand Li thumper let's do
two more second grade u.s. geography
which of the following states extends
the farthest south Utah New Mexico
Nebraska New Mexico extends or is are
they asking like which state is the
longest no that it's got to be New
Mexico what are the answer Nebraska Utah
New Mexico yeah absolutely New Mexico
it says Albuquerque New Mexico
3:06 Negra Arroyo Lane no that's a
breaking bad thing all right
fourth grade animal science which of the
following is an anthropoid okay be ape
Lobster wait which is along its report
oh it's a lobster I thought you'd like B
was
it's an ape he's an anthropocentric
[Music]
thanks Siri useless all right let's do
one more that was a bad one
third grade world geography which of
these is not an independent country
Greenland Iceland Sri Lanka independent
country I guess your Lanka I would think
Sri Lanka but I don't know what that
means I don't know I mean I'm so bad at
this stuff anything like history
geography it just was so bad at and I'm
really sorry it just doesn't go in my
brain what's the answer
Greenland we're getting like I've been
destroyed right now I got a D one time
in history history was my [ __ ] I forgot
that with a tutor 1st grade animal
science true or false the platypus is a
mammal true even though it lays eggs
true even though it lays eggs it says I
swear to God it dead really yeah it's a
platypus lays eggs but it still new
they're cute 1st grade music what is the
fifth word in the star-spangled banner
let's see right light C hey can you see
see it's red no it's not yet see I don't
know I feel like we're borderline dumber
than fifth graders yeah well I know that
about myself I'm not good at anything
history or geography it's really hard
for me but everything else [ __ ] like
managed but at the same time well really
done I want a couple more why don't you
do more than having fun okay you do you
didn't worry I just don't like it
just you to me I'm not good at it I only
want to do things them like feels so
dumb wait I don't know which ones you
did okay let's do third grade ancient
cultures what was the primary language
used in Rome
was it a Latin be Italian or C Greek
ancient Rome yeah I think it's Latin
he's Greek anyone could know Latin
the answer is
Italian became the official language in
Italy in 1867 I answer was stupid
no that's smart and he's cute and he's
smarter than a fifth grader yeah oh are
you trying to face somebody second grade
music true or false
on a standard piano the farthest key on
the left will make a higher pitch sound
than the farthest key on the right horse
absolutely the opposite all right fourth
grade science the alloy bronze is
traditionally made by combining tin with
what other metallic element copper I
think you might be right because 10 is
traditionally silver right no I guess
that would be my answer too because I
don't have a better answer it is copper
oh is it
yeah so you take tinfoil and you wrap a
penny in it and you throw it against the
wall and you've gotten third place you
got bronze Wow congratulations
alright second grade life science speech
a baby
this is frog frog is known as a tadpole
or what other name a zygote be minnow or
sea Polliwog Polliwog I think where's
that the name of Pokemon did you ever
know it's a Polliwog did you only whirl
is the name of the Pope did you do that
when you're in school and you like have
well I think we mess with them
I can't we like do that for learning
purposes as adult sector frog in milk in
high school though I know that was
brutal we had to do a fetal pig - oh
yeah we just had to do a frog and I will
never get the smell of that formaldehyde
yeah out of my brain the fetal pig was
ready to move oh damn that [ __ ] was
brutal
it sure was Beach okay fourth grade u.s.
geography this is all me baby the names
of how many US states begin with Oh
Delaware Florida Georgia Hawaii Idaho
Illinois Indiana Iowa Kansas Kentucky
Louisiana Maine Maryland Massachusetts
Michigan Minnesota Mississippi Missouri
Montana Nebraska Nevada extreme New York
North Carolina North Dakota Ohio
Oklahoma Oregon Pennsylvania
three I got their first grade animal
science true or false the primary reason
woodpeckers Peck at trees is so that
they can eat the wood no that's all
they're trying to get bugs right we're
trying to get things out of the wood
they're not trying to eat that yeah
they're trying to remove the wood to get
the insects underneath you [ __ ] dummy
there are animals that he would though
really yeah pests wood destroying pests
termite yeah do they I think they do I
don't know what they do honestly well
the wood goes somewhere do they like
shred it onto the ground though don't
they I don't know maybe they eat away at
it but don't heat it yeah I don't know
if somebody like eats wood yeah I don't
know well like a like a weevil what do
they do
why don't you look up weevil I don't
know robots I love being highly all
right first grade world geography
completed in 1889 the Eiffel Tower
stands in what city Paris very difficult
Paris Italy
[Laughter]
SiC I love Paris Italy first grade
science for centuries silk used in
clothing has traditionally come from
what animal spiders lambs or
caterpillars silk spiders I think you're
right nope it's caterpillars spiders
what the [ __ ] is wrong with me are you
spider I like their webs they're pretty
I don't know I'm not a fan of silk okay
honestly it's kind of gross now that I
really think about it that's real gross
mm-hmm y'all really out here wearing a
bunch of caterpillars [ __ ] on you
bastards disgusting y'all nasty
disgusting why are you crying I think he
wants us to be done yeah Kermit is it
time bud well if you played along
there's no question that you did better
than us so congrats on being smarter
than not only a fifth grader but us as
well there are so many of these
questions we could do this a number of
more times it's seven seven hundred and
seventy-six questions
Wow it's a lot of questions I just kind
of skipped around but um yeah I don't
know thanks for listening us see if
we're smarter than it is actually fun
because it like it reminds you you know
what you were good at and what your [ __ ]
at when you were in school I'm still
[ __ ] algebra in history that's my [ __ ]
dude I can't my brain doesn't work it
just doesn't remember you could tell me
the answer a thousand times in a row and
I'd forget it tomorrow it doesn't go
into my something about solving an
algebra equation was so satisfying it is
I loved that feeling especially if it
was a long one that's all I have to say
No thank you guys for hanging out and
shouts out to our sponsors make sure if
you're diversity of them it supports the
thousand-foot link in the video
description check those out and I'll see
you guys next week for another podcast
we are borderline smarter than fifth
graders but also dumber that's up to you
thank you guys have a great week goodbye
[Music]
[Music]